[Music]
oh hey Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you almost ready to go to
size 4 rest huh how you so big look at
the big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my kid
Down clean up on6 sorry about the mess
hold
on oh hey b hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burned me my wife and three kids
have you told them yet I'll tell them
when I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in
3 days this is crazy oh to God we're
going to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip stop collate and list back with a
new 5 hours on a plane or 33 hours in a
car can someone unlock the car
please call in
everybody I want him
found what was that little pothole
Maxi's been up the whole time by the
way where's
that before I met you mom I was a covert
assassin I escaped that life and now
they found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
us look at you playing the family man
I'm not playing this is my
life hey I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait
wait new
[Music]
record